Film Courage: We had a comment on our channel the
other day and it lends to something that
we were just talking about off-camera
and just about having certain people on
your production that are in your camp
and you said someone to give an advice
to someone you know? Daniel Stamm, Filmmaker: Yes, a friend of
mine as a female director was very
successful in TV right now and when she
before she did her first episode she
asked some other huge TV director I
forget who that was if you had to give
me one piece of advice what would that
be
and he said make sure you have someone
that is on your team meaning that has
not been hired by production has not
been suggested by the producers but
someone that you have worked with and
trust and that you bring into the
project which it doesn't seem obvious in
the beginning because you are so taken
by all the great talented people that
production is throwing at you that you
are happily taking that one that one
that one in the beginning everything is
rosy anyway the energy is like
everybody's excited there are no
problems but but I think the process the
process is one where no matter how great
the producers are that you work with I
always look at them in the beginning and
go like I know we're going to have a
screaming fight at some part doesn't
matter how great they are it's just it's
like you're going through this war
together you're exhausted and you don't
have a hundred percent overlapping
worldview and create a fuse otherwise
you'd be the same person just by virtue
of not being the same person that
friction especially with the money
involved will at some point lead to the
moment where you find yourself on set
being screamed at by that person
screaming at that person and having to
figure out the next moment after that so
that's always what I'm in my mind
jumping ahead to and collect do I want
to do that with that person does that
person seem reasonable and human enough
that we will survive that moment and
it's not going to taint everything into
bitterness and then connected to that is
this bring your own person because you
will find yourself in a situation where
everything is so crazy
their conflicts and you are not
completely sure that it's not you going
crazy especially because if production
comes with all their people they owe
each other
loyalty like if you have a TV show for
example where they've already done 10
episodes I'm doing the 11th episode this
whole team has me unset for a week but
knows that then the next year of their
employment depends on being in good
graces with the producers if there now
is a conflict you will not suddenly have
the team stand up for you which honor on
a movie set you would because you put
the team together you stuck your heads
together creatively to make this happen
and if there's a conflict with the money
side of things
you are anchored in your creative people
that give you that the confidence that
you are pursuing the right thing for the
right reason entity you don't have that
person so what she was saying to even
have one person there with as she
brought her cinematographer where she
said no I want to hire my own team a
terrible model made a world of a
difference because she knew that she in
one li on set and again it's really hard
and sounds very negative to think of
conflict in the beginning when
everything is just fireworks and
everything is great but I think that's a
smart way to do and if there is no
conflict I have yet to see that set
where there is no conflict and if that
happens to be the case then great you
know but at least you have some kind of
insurance of having someone who has your
back and is not beholden to the
producers
well there's a honeymoon phase for
everything whether it's a new job
whatever it is
so yeah everyone's gonna be on their
best behavior right and then people's
preferences and quirks and everything
comes out later and then yeah are you
able to recover from it and still be
cordial and professional with each other
even after a blow-up right or does that
person hold a grudge and then to have
someone in your own camp I think that's
great and also as a sounding board
somewhat not not as like a full
emotional sounding board but someone to
basically you can run something by like
was that when I gave that was that clear
and
that's helpful and that context the
greatest thing of course if you can
bring someone on that you've worked with
before that can give you context of what
we did we did it before like that what
they want now it's different the moment
you can see what you do in a context
with a little bit of background I think
it's super helpful that's maybe a luxury
to have that you have someone who is as
professional at functions on that higher
level that the production would say yes
we will hire your person instead of our
person that is probably hard to achieve
but if it can be achieved and that is a
big plus I think what if a filmmaker
finds themselves in a situation where
they can tell their that the production
is running away from them and they are
it feels like their head spinning and
everyone sort of got their own agenda
how do they make it through even if they
say okay this is not gonna go well but I
need to contractually eat you know I'm
contractually obliged to continue this
and I'm gonna stay there and tough it
out how do you kind of keep your sanity
I think that is the answer what you just
if you just yeah you're there it hasn't
happened to me in that better form and I
do wonder that myself because it's so
demanding to be unset even in the best
of circumstances that if it's a
nightmare atmosphere continually over
days and weeks I don't know how people
how people do it but I guess if you are
getting paid for it then you just
concentrate on that and call it every
day that I'm on set I'm getting paid and
if I was working in an office
environment I would hate it too but I'd
go to get paid so I'm doing that now and
I'm trying to not reduce my my sanity
and then if that can be achieved at all
I'm always trying to remind myself how
cool it is that I get to do this and
that I get to see this even if the
nightmare how amazing that I get to see
an oscar-winning actor be a diva and be
hated by every but I get to see it from
the first role like I'm in a Hollywood
how great is that
and you always forget that because
you're so in and you go no I
keep this and I don't want to get to set
bubble but if you have a little bit of a
distance which in TV is much easier
because it's not your baby that you have
written and nurtured over years and you
now see fall apart but it's an episode
that someone else wrote and you are just
there to kind of make it literally
through the day and then it's a little
bit easier I think just step back but
again then it helps if you can turn to
someone at the end of the day and can
roll your eyes with them and you know
that that wasn't a normal day whereas if
you don't have that person and you start
getting a feeling that you are the one
that is off and that this is a normal
condition that you're working with I
think then it can really kind of eat
away at you sure that's where you just
kind of keep it so awhile great weather
today right yeah yeah Gary sir I mean at
some point really it's about making
making it through the day and shooting
the stuff that is on the page keep
shooting keep shooting keep shooting it
really in the end the only recipe you
just have to really let go of plans that
you had and how you imagined this if you
get I think card in the spiral of
frustration I have that I'm Anna when
you're not in a good way
that perfectionist in that I get very
demotivated very quickly if I have the
feeling we're compromising quality right
and that that and adds up because I'm if
we do in the in the first day I'm
already in day to slightly less
motivated to achieve what in my
delusional mind I think would be this
great cultural masterpiece right and and
so then you get you have to be careful
not to get caught up in the frustration
of that because every day it will be
worse because the first day you
compromise the second day you have to
compromise before it because you
compromise the first day
so the third day and gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and in the end you get
you could get to the dangerous moment of
I don't care anymore you know and to
save yourself from that I think it's
it's good to click go a little bit in
the beginning and almost ideally see the
humor and I'd go like let's see where
this goes but I still have to deliver
obviously the pages that we have to
shoot every day and then we'll see an
editing if we
safe this time that's probably how that
would go
you